Cuáles son las principales amenazas
medioambientales que tienen en riesgo
América Latina
bueno Muchas gracias por la invitación y
la consideración en general América
Latina tiene una significación muy
particular dentro de la crisis ecológica
y fundamentalmente climática por sus
niveles altos de desigualdad sus altos
niveles de biodiversidad y también su
rol dentro de la economía Global en ese
sentido podemos interpretar de acuerdo a
diversos informes científicos
fundamentalmente
cinco grandes amenazas ambientales la
primera es la que tiene que ver con la
deforestación los incendios forestales y
la producción agrícola que afectan a los
bosques la salud humana la agricultura y
la biodiversidad por otro lado tenemos
la quema de combustibles fósiles que
genera una contaminación del aire que ha
llegado a representar 4.5 millones de
muertes anuales en todo el año por
último tenemos un consumo totalmente
responsable e inconsciente que
contribuye de Gran manera al cambio
climático ya que según un estudio de la
ONU el consumo en las ciudades causas
del 70% de todas las emisiones Asimismo
el consumo de plásticos llega a invadir
ciudades además de contaminar mares Ríos
manglares principalmente Y por último
tenemos un transporte y una movilidad
como uno de los principales generadores
de emisiones de carbono que repercuten
en el ambiente y en la salud de las
personas bueno Y ante esas amenazas que
usted acaba de mencionar Qué acciones
deben tomar las autoridades para
contrarrestar los fenómenos climáticos
extremos
por supuesto bueno de manera un poco
general la política digamos tiene que
superar estas dinámicas corruptas y
generar política pública bioética y
anclada también a la cooperación
internacional mientras transicionan el
modelo económico hacia una transición
ecológica En ese sentido hay algunos
ejes que son fundamentales para esta
transición ecosocial el primero es
esencial de tener la deforestación
exacerbada que se vive no una
restauración de bosques y una
regeneración ecosistémica mientras se
promueve la producción alimentaria como
la agroecología y en general la
producción climáticamente inteligente
Así mismo necesitamos hacer más eficaces
las políticas de regulación de las
actividades extractivas evaluar los
impactos en perpacidad de Estas
actividades y mejorar la gestión del
conocimiento para promover alternativas
económicas y en ese sentido generar una
economía que sirva a las personas y Que
respete la vida desde las necesidades
sociales y los límites naturales en ese
sentido también necesitamos mejorar la
gestión de desechos e ir hacia un modelo
basura cero Y por último implementar
estrategias que permitan replantear los
sistemas de transporte y movilidad de
modo que sean sostenibles
psicológicamente y también que
incorporen evidentemente criterios de
bienestar ciudadano bueno nosotros
hablamos mucho de acciones a gran escala
Pero qué puede hacer cada persona para
minimizar o reducir el impacto humano en
la tierra
por supuesto Y esa pregunta es
fundamental porque no hay cambio social
sin una transformación cultural y la
transformación cultural precisamente
empieza con el cambio de cada una y cada
uno de nosotros En ese sentido primero
es entender que vivimos en una sociedad
de consumo que nos vende ideas de
felicidad y de libertad que debemos
interrogar Debemos entender que si bien
hay empresas que generan sus productos a
partir de explotación social y de una
explosión y de una explotación natural y
totalmente exacerbada e inconcebible es
precisamente porque hay personas que le
compran en ese sentido hay que
interrogar nuestros hábitos de consumo
desde un consumo mucho más consciente y
también de entender qué es lo que
realmente necesitamos no O sea
replantear no tanto desde Estas ideas de
estatus que nos venden sino realmente
desde nuestras necesidades profundas que
necesitamos Y cómo nosotros podemos
hacer de nuestra vida cotidiana y de
nuestro consumo cotidiano una si para
una mejor realidad una realidad que
recupere nuestra armonía con la
naturaleza